R
A PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE THEY
WILL FLY THEM TO THE STATE OF
THEIR CHOICE.
WHETHER PSAKI IS IN FRONT OF A
PODIUM OR ON THE NEWS SHE WILL
BE DOING THE SAME THING, LYING.
THE BEST MEDIA PERSONALITY, THE
ONLY OBJECTIVE ONE, NOT PART OF
THE BLUE CHECK MEDIA MOB ON
TWITTER WHO SHOULD HAVE HIS OWN
TV SHOW ON FOX.
ANYWAY, JOE, I THOUGHT SUSAN
ASKING HUMPTY DUMP TY THE
QUESTION.
HE NAILED IT.
>> AN 18-YEAR-OLD JUST THREW
CNN'S CHIEF MEDIA -- SOMETHING
THAT IS AN EXPERT ON FOR ALL THE
WRONG REASONS.
LET'S GO THROUGH THESE STUDENTS
POINTS.
CHRISTOPHER PHILLIP.
IN HIS QUESTION ONE BY ONE.
HE SAYS TRADITIONAL MEDIA.
THAT'S LIKE CNN, ABC, CBS, NBC.
HE SAID THEY PUSHED THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX.
THAT'S CORRECT.
HE SAID THEY PUSHED THE JESSIE
SMOLLETT HOAX.
THAT IS CORRECT.
HE SAID THEY SMEARED JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
THEY DISMISSED THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAP TOP AFFAIR AS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
BINGO.
ALL THE MISTAKES OF THE MAIN
STREAM MEDIA, CNN HE SAID IN
PARTICULAR, GO IN ONE DIRECTION.
I BELIEVE I HAVE HEARD THAT
SOMEWHERE BEFORE.
STELTER ANSWERS THAT RIGHT WING
NARRATIVE ABOUT CNN.
HE DOES THIS WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE.
HE PERCEIVES NOT TO ADDRESS ANY
OF THE POINTS THE STUDENT MADE.
WE KNOW NOW THAT THIS IS A
CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF THE RIGHT
WING MEDIA MACHINE.
THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE PLAY
BOOK.
STORIES DAMAGING THE DEMOCRATS
OR MEDIA.
BLAME THE RIGHT WING MEDIA.
BLAME RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
WE WONDER WHY MORE AMERICANS SEE
JOURNALISTS AS ACTIVISTS.
ONCE THAT TRUST IS BROKEN, IT IS
VERY HARD TO PUT HUMPTY DUMPTY
BACK TOGETHER.
>> Sean: HARD TO SEE WHETHER HIS
STEPBOGRAPHY GETS TO STAY WITH
NEW MANAGEMENT COMING IN.
>> I HAVE TO AGREE.
THAT COMMENT FROM ANNE APPLEBAUM
IS ALSO TYPICAL OF THE MEDIA
LANDSCAPE YOU JUST DESCRIBED,
SEAN.
ANNE APPLEBAUM WAS A
DISTINGUISHED HISTORIAN OF
RUSSIA, MUCH MORE.
IN RECENT YEARS SHE WENT BANANAS
ABOUT THE ELECTION RESULTS SHE
COULDN'T ACCEPT.
HER HUSBAND AND HIS POWER WAS
PUT OUT OF POWER.
SHE DIDN'T LIKE BREXIT.
ON AND ON THROUGH DONALD TRUMP.
NOW WE HAVE HER SAYING ON THIS
PANEL ABOUT DISINFORMATION.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
SHE WOULDN'T HAVE COVERED THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAP TOP STORY
BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT THAT
INTERESTING TO ME.
NOT THAT INTERESTING?
THE SON OF THE SOON TO BE THEN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
WHO THEN WOULD BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WAS EARNING
$50,000 A MONTH IN A DISCIPLINE
HE DOES NOT HAVE, IN AN AREA HE
KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT, IN A
COUNTRY HE BARELY KNOWS.
THAT'S NOT INTERESTING TO HER.
IT'S NOT INTERESTING TO ANNE
APPLEBAUM.
AS WE KNOW FROM THE LAP TOP FROM
HELL, YOU JUST MENTIONED HUNTER
BIDEN SAID THE BIG MAN, HIS
FATHER, TAKES A PERCENTAGE OF
ALL HIS MONEY.
IS THAT NOT INTERESTING TO
PEOPLE?
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS.
AS YOU KNOW, SEAN, WE HAVE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE MAKING UP
STUFF ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
WE HAVE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
OPERATIVES PRETENDING THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAP TOP STORY WAS RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION.
THEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECOME
RIGHTLY SUSPICIOUS OF ALL OF THE
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
UKRAINE, RUSSIA, ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE SERIOUS
FOREIGN POLICY ISSUES, ALMOST
UNMENTIONABLE IN WASHINGTON
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL DOMESTIC
ISSUES.
WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THEIR
DOMESTIC WARS OVER